The Joe Rogan experience, but I think
Pete, I'm Deborah tried DMT. Oh,
I think he's too measured for that. Well,
I think he would want to know. You know,
maybe, I bet he's done a lot of shit. He
does whatever he wants. Yeah, for sure.
Czar. How many, how many checks do you
think he's gotten? A stable? Well, I,
I will tell you this, I truly
believe this. I think that he does.
He can just sit there and he has
women flock to him. Oh, for sure.
They love him for sure.
The best looking woman in the world.
He doesn't have to do anything.
Right. This kind of power.
My wife was like, he's,
he's hot. Whoa. I go, but he's,
he's a gangster. She goes,
who doesn't like a gangster? Ooh. And I
was like, Ooh, Geez. I had to walk away.
I was like, oh, it's
uncomfortable. Steal your girl.
Yeah, I'll take your girl. Yeah.
Still your,
your football ring here.
But that know the story about
fucking steroidal told me about this.
He, uh, who was the football
player where Putin stole his ring.
Google that the owner of the Patriots
wasn't him. It wasn't a player,
it was just the owner of the Patriots. Is
that the guy that craft that guy? Okay.
So he had this a Superbowl ring
on, he meets Putin. Putin says,
can I hold the dream? You know, and then
like takes the ring off, puts it on.
It's like, hmm. And he
said something like,
you could smash someone's
face with this ring.
And laughed and then just walked off with
the ring and they were like, Hey, uh,
where's the ring? He's like, no,
he just stole the ring. You know,
Harvey Keitel really just took his
ring money ring. No, that's awesome.
This murdering a dick.
So he just decided he wanted it and took
it off the guy's hand and was laughing
and walked off with it.
As the story goes crap hand to the
diamond studded ring to Putin is a bit of
show and tell I could
kill someone to string.
Putin reportedly said as
he fitted to his finger.
Then when Kraft held out his hand to
get it back Pruett and surrounded by KGB
agents, wordlessly slipped
the ring into his pocket. Wow.
News circulated quickly.
The brain was not meant to as a gift,
which prompted craft to issue
this statement at the time.
At the end of a very productive three hour
business meeting with President Putin,
I showed the president my most
recent Superbowl ring, Kraft said,
upon seeing the ring president,
Putin,
a great knowledgeable sports fan
was clearly taken by its uniqueness.
At that point,
I decided to give him the
rings as a symbol of the
respect and admiration that I
have for the Russian people and the
leadership of President Putin, Aka,
I want to live. I want
to love it. I dig this,
this muttering. No, I do.
I do have an admiration.
I just think you think he's ever killed
anybody with a ring? Uh, yes. Probably.
He was the guy from beating
people to death. George W.
Bush administration had pressured him at
the time to let go of the ring to avoid
an international incident. Hilarious. Wow.
In 2013 craft reneged and offered
some backstory about the incident.
A legging alleging that
the Bush administration had
pressured him at the time to
let go of the ring.
Wow.
It would really be in the best interest
of us Soviet relations if you meant to
give the ring as a present craft
or crawls the White House saying,
I really didn't want to. I
had an emotional tie to the
ring. It has my name on it.
Kraft said, I didn't want to see it
on Ebay, but maybe putting ms stuff,
you know there's a language barrier,
so he probably miss. Understood.
Listen what he's saying. No, he
didn't shut the fuck up. They will.
You have Russian propaganda agent.
There was a pause at the other end
of the line and the White House voice
repeated.
It would really be in the best interest
if you meant to give the ring as a
painful, I'm putting a faith, bro.
No, I'm saying shut down your podcast.
He took that ring.
He punked that dude and took his ring.
It's not yet a thief. He's gangster. Yeah.
It's out there pumping like Harvey
Keitel to drop 124 diamonds.
The Great Harvey Keitel. Yes. Tell me
a story. I think it was him. They said,
you know, remember the Akita?
What? No. Um, what's that?
What's that fucking that left
him. Nikita La femme. Nikita.
Remember the actress in the TV
show? Yes, I met her once. She was,
she went to Russia. Candy
Alexander. So tell ask. Okay,
so she went to Russia with her boyfriend.
The Putin likes her.
He used to watch the show all the time.
I heard this from,
I think it was Harvey Keitel.
He kept that dude out into another room
and had her out on the balcony talking
to her the whole time.
And basically he,
the guy couldn't get back in and it was
very clear that Putin was making a play
for La Femme, Nikita. And then it's like,
you're in my town now. You go over there,
take a seat. I know you came here and take
a seat. I'm going to take what's mine.
And apparently she was gone. I don't
think she did anything, obviously,
but you know, let's pretend she
did right there. It is. It is.
And he dug her was, oh, Jack
Nicholson turning around, Bro.
[inaudible] boyfriend's not
around. He's not there, Bro.
He's not allowed to be at his table.
You have legs for this.
He was apparently locked out.
He was like trying to get in the room and
there was, sorry. We didn't know. Wow.
It's kind of interesting when you see a
guy running a country like that in 2019
that he can run the country
in that gangster fashion
more and saying that he got
people to Sean Penn.
Yeah.
It's more interesting to me that he's
gotten himself in a position where people
would actually vote for. So
it technically, he's been
democratically elected.